cette génisse comme celle ci va partir
dans quinze jours
elle est vendue 3 81 kg de viande 3
euros 80 insuffisant pour cet éleveur il
estime qu'il lui faudrait près d'un euro
de plus pour s'en sortir
la matière première augmente partout
l'aliment dans les coopératives fait que
d'augmenter et en plus bas comme on
subit deux années consécutives de
sécheresse
lemay fourrage coûte de plus en plus
cher donc ça devient de plus en plus
compliqué quoi au total nicolas masi
considère que ces charges ont augmenté
d'environ 270 euros par bête en deux ans
une situation qui touche toute la
profession
le revenu moyen mensuel des éleveurs
allaitants a baissé de 20% en 2019
pourtant dans les rayons des magasins la
tendance n'est pas la même dans cette
grande surface de l'agglomération
dijonnaise
il faut compter 2 15 euros le kilo de
boeuf à plus d'une quarantaine d'euros
pour certaines pièces un contraste
difficilement acceptable pour cet
éleveur gpda carrément 20,42 euros 10 le
tournedos moi ce morceau là je les vends
du 3 80 kw à 7 quoi énerver un peu parce
que on se rend compte que notre produit
c'est un produit noble qui vendent un
vin qui font une marge bénéficiaire à
mon avis assez exceptionnel et nous
derrière
on n'a pas de on n'a pas de on est pas
considéré quoi aucune considération
aucune considération et un dialogue avec
la grande distribution qui semble
impossible selon les éleveurs